à 77 ans joe biden est un homme
politique chevronné sénateur démocrate
pendant 37 ans il maîtrise les arcanes
du congrès une expérience qui a attiré
l'attention de barack obama pendant ces
huit années de mandat à la tête des
états unis ce dernier lui confie la vice
présidence mais il aura fallu 3
convention démocrate pour voir l'ancien
colistier de barack obama s'est lancé
dans la course à la maison blanche face
à donald trump grand honneur et une
grande humilité
j'accepte cette investiture pour la
présidence des états unis d'amérique
à plusieurs reprises sa vie privée a
fait obstacle à sa vie politique
en 1972 il perd sa première épouse et sa
fille dans un accident de voiture
il a seulement 30 ans et entame son
premier mandat de sénateur plus en 2015
son fils beau meurt d'un cancer ce deuil
le pousse à renoncer à l'investiture
démocrate 2020 en année de la
consécration dans la continuité des
candidats démocrates précédent il
s'engage dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique contre les
armes à feu et les discriminations
raciales et en faveur d'une meilleure
couverture santé alors que les violences
policières le blacklight matters et la
pandémie de provident 19 se sont invités
en pleine campagne électorale
joe biden se voit en rassembleur et
protecteur minaj qu'ils votent en
opposition à celle de son adversaire
mes amis la première responsabilité d'un
président et de protéger le peuple
américain mais il ne le fait pas cela le
disqualifie totalement croix récemment
des accusations sont venues ternir son
image geste déplacé envers des
collaboratrices est affaire de
corruption internationale par
l'intermédiaire de son fils hunter
des accusations démenties sans effet de
manche
hayden se repose sur une réputation
bâtie de longue haleine né en
pennsylvanie dans une famille catholique
modeste proche de milieu ouvrier
il a gravi les échelons politiques 1 à 1
celui qui fut élu le plus jeune sénateur
démocrate en 1972 franchi aujourd'hui la
plus haute marche de sa carrière en
devenant président des états unis arrivé